暗くピートなんですよね
ギザを刻んじゃっている
水の方
止められています
もおおぉ
表現と言う10日
なんか色んな実践考えるのは
半沢人気の部分内面的なと思うっていうのがどっか申請してくればイースそうですね
ストリーダーすっていうとそのアウトローがやるものみたいなイメージがあって
だからといってこうおっしゃられて下げてあればうまくなるっても
そこがやっぱり
基本的な動きがあったりとかやっぱりその真剣にやらないと身につかないものを
たくさん安定するんで
そこが本当に一緒だと思うんですねだからその
スタイル学違うだけであってそのう
そこをしっかり高を身につけて
表現していくということに関しては33おっしゃっているん
元もすごく
一緒だっていうのはありますね
本当にこうずっと長く続けてきたものを
があるとしたらそれを先へ続ける
つなげていくっていうのは実は店頭の最先端にいる今生きている自分であり生きている
人たちに伝える作業なんですね
もずっとなーい飛んでるが
後ろに続いているのは私が発端じゃないですね
私がやらなきゃいけばこの先を掘り続けていくことそれは今に生きている人に伝える
ためにどういう方法がいいのかな
それが実は革新していく
ございます
ポイントはひょっとするときちっとすることなのか
ていることが何か様々のされているストリートダンスの中で私たちがやっている園生も
舞台のって言う
まじ所作でも実はこっちが堅苦しくて
こっちは面白くないとかそういう話じゃなくて
実はどっちもきちっとする中で伝える
中田も本質にあるものを
たりで表現しながら伝えられたらいいんだ
きちっとすることをちゃんとすることっていうのはなんかめんどくさい事をか壊れる
ことじゃない
そうですねこんなに難しいのかとか
自分が今までやったことのない動きが凄いやっぱ8位
いうことを感じて
ただ
肉体表現っていう意味では普段の自分たちがあってもんと一緒になろう
こう思ったからじゃこういう動きっていうのは
[音楽]
こう生かせるんじゃないかとか
いうことがまあ先にしていけるんじゃないかなということを今
少ないしながらなんだ
ていければと思います
きていく中で何が必要かともやっぱり
やかましい話をやろうとしているわけじゃないんですけれどでも脳もストーリーって
必ずのメッセージがあるんですね
人は本当はどうして生きなきゃいけないとか
それがうれしいば目悲しい場面の
お腹で表現することによってあだったら自分は次とうなるは買わなきゃいけないと
もっとそれが今世界中で唱えられている
sd 地ズって言うところの物の考え方とか精神に本当につながるものは実脳の根底に
はありました
なんかそういうものを立つと一緒に
表現しながら
人って本当はこういう風にしなきゃいけないんだよねっていうようなことが伝えられた
ストリートダンスと
童虎コラボレーションというかミックスして新しいものを生み出すかっていうことの一
つヒントにはなるかなと思っているので
分かって今思っていることとか感じてることっていうのは忘れないようにしようと思っ
てるんですね
ん
ています
[拍手]
ren
me
none
[音楽]
uh
me
うううう
wh
me
[音楽]
ん
me
re
today
me
てっぺんっ
[音楽]
me
can can
[音楽]
んの
[拍手]